[Music]
for the breaking news story the body of
Emmett Lewis Hill has been found dead
[Music]
one of the first things I was really
struck by when learning more about who
Mamie was was how incredibly intentional
she was of how she was being perceived
and received and being able to use that
in a way that would help to create some
sort of change most of us would not know
who Emmett Till was if it weren't for me
we get to see how Mimi fights for
justice we get to see how she changes
are coming to understand that black
people are all connected that all people
are deeply connected if something is
happening to one of us it is happening
to all of us there were a few times most
notably Mimi's testimony
I was speechless
he's brilliant
there will be no pictures taken during
court proceedings it's been an effort
trying to get the story of Emmett Till
on the big screen being able to work
side by side with my producing Partners
Fred Zolo Barbara Brockley Whoopi
Goldberg Thomas Levine and Michael Riley
it's been truly truly a blessing
we tried to get it set up somewhere and
we got a lot of no's
but we kept we kept at it
I was also able to work with Mother
Mobley for eight years until she
unfortunately passed away it was her
encouragement that pushed me to tell the
story she did this I think for 40 some
odd years fought and fought to get
Justice for Emmett I've been waiting 10
and a half years Getting It produced
Keith Beauchamp has been waiting 28
years he's the reason we were able to
get the case reopened
I think it's very important that we put
Emmett's story in his proper context and
history to understand how his story
became the Catalyst that sparked the
American Civil Rights Movement
the murder of Emmett Till was considered
the trial of a century that you could
read the journalistic sources of the
time so there's no shortage of books no
shortage of documentary evidence maybe
till Mobley she was a very public figure
so we didn't have to do much guesswork
about the way in which she represented
Emmett's memory her pain and what she
wanted this is Bradley I'd like you to
meet Ruby
it's truly an honor to making this
friend thank you
[Music]
educated but also her mother was a
tailor so she had a knack for fashion I
feel this is a rendering of what made me
tell War at trial and this is historic
so this was a matter of reading my own
rendering picking out this fabric to
create hard top and then we have
the starburst pleated skirt that she
wears to the trial
there were color palettes that I focused
on in the beginning maybe is wearing
something very bright as the time goes
on her color digresses
and we spoke with the prosecution team
only once before on the phone it was
brief
get together Smith
Mrs Brown Maybe
from the minute she walks into that
courtroom
turns to her right and the door opens
and 12 white men
consisting of the jury come out and at
that point she already knows the verdict
so it's not a testimony of changing
hearts and minds but it's a testimony of
appealing to the humanity and people
[Music]
the first thing I noticed when I became
a mother
was that my hands were busy
all the time
rocking carrying swaying always full
one hand for him and one hand for what
he needed
when it came time to place him down so
he could make his own way around
I touched every inch of him
every Bend
my hand knew him with my eyes closed
just like I know his laughter in a
crowded room
it's the same thing
when you know all of someone
Danielle
was made for this role I needed an actor
who can hold a frame I needed an actor
who is able to have screen presence and
a magnetism that makes audiences hooked
and captivated and want to watch you for
two hours I needed an actor who can
communicate the complexity and the
layers that this character embodies
a mother knows
your mother would know
and I knew I knew this was my boy
Emmett Till
Beyond any doubt
with the way Danielle that while you're
acted like the courtroom scene with this
incredible array of emotions starting
from a very subtle things right that you
only see in the corner of her mouth
sometimes we decided not to even try to
touch it with score in terms of the
score I was asked to only score the
internal emotions and the
Transformations and and this layer
without kind of touching the external
worlds any story you see the
transformation once you realize this is
like bigger than like it can't you know
this this is something else now that
that I have to stand up for
you've been quoted in the colored press
I told him several times before I left
the Mississippi that he should kneel in
the street and beg for forgiveness
should he ever insult a white person not
those exact words
did you caution him not to insult white
women I referred to white people in
general
did you caution your son how to conduct
himself and behave himself while he was
down here in Mississippi several times
several times do tell us how
I will give you a literal description of
what I told him how coming down here he
would have to adapt himself to a
different way of life be very careful
about how he spoke and to whom he spoke
and to always remember to say yes sir
and no ma'am I told him that if ever an
incident should arise where there would
be any trouble of any kind with white
people that if it got to the point where
he needed to go down on his knees before
them well I told him not to hesitate to
do so
like if he bumped into somebody on the
street
and they might get belligerent or
something well I told him to go ahead
and humble himself so as not to get into
any trouble but
but what
well I raised him with love for 14 years
my sudden warnings about hate weren't
going to get through
and I'll show you what purports to be a
photograph of you son
this was taken in my home two days after
Christmas
now tell the court and the jury what
this is
this picture is of my son
after Mississippi sent him back to
Chicago dead
and in that scene we shot take one and
of course again I'm shaking with wasabs
chinoids as an another take you could
hear a pin drop in the courtroom and
then she'd only calls me over and she
was like am I crazy but do we need any
other shots in this scene
I was like I'm mesmerized from the First
Take
I was speechless and so I was having I
had a lot of those moments I think all
the crew all the
all that had those moments after some of
Danielle's cakes
Shivers went up and down my spine and
the entire cast and crew gave her a
standing ovation
it's the first time in my life I've ever
seen that happen
it's interesting how when you're really
in something
and the technical just drops away and
you're just in the emotionality of
something the idea is that the truth
will always be the truth and no matter
how much you try to Mar the truth
standing right in front of your face and
a mother's heart
that's like the truth that's not
something you make up
[Music]
working with shinoya we were deeply
rooted with each other I love and
respect her for how we've been able to
pull these roots up and allow this kind
of Storytelling to Blossom
we're navigating a balance the full
spectrum of the experience of it and
maybe that's how you respect and move
through something as weighted and
valuable as this experience is in
history and as it is in a retelling
when you can hook audiences through
story and through craft then you got
them and they'll be better able to
receive the humanity of this person who
looked different from them
[Music]